queremos ver dónde f x iguala x al cubo
menos 12 x 4 alcanza máximos o mínimos
como ya platicamos en vídeos pasados
esto básicamente se reduce a encontrar
sus puntos críticos entonces lo primero
que vamos a hacer es calcular la
derivada de f porque junto al justo los
puntos críticos es donde la derivada o
bien nuestra definida o bien se anula y
para derivar la pues simplemente tenemos
un polinomio a que hay algunos x algunas
potencias entonces este término derivado
es 3x al cuadrado este de aquí es menos
12 y como aquí tenemos una constante y
la constante no cambia cuando cambia x
entonces tenemos 0 verdad entonces la
derivada sería 3x cuadrada menos 12
ahora esto está definido para cualquier
valor de x verdad no hay problema
poniendo ningún valor de x de este modo
los únicos puntos críticos van a ser
aquellos en los cuales 3x cuadrada menos
12 sea igual a 0 entonces para encontrar
estos puntos vamos a despejar x lo
primero que vamos a hacer es sumar 12 de
ambos lados nos quedaría que 3 x al
cuadrado es igual a 12 y luego
dividiendo entre 3 nos queda
x al cuadrado es igual a 12 entre 3 a 4
muy bien y aquí tenemos dos chances
sacando la raíz cuadrada un chance es
que sea igual a 2 y el otro chance es
que x x sea igual a menos 2 va nada más
para ver que todo va muy bien déjame ver
si en efecto ahí se anula la derivada
entonces f prima de 2 nos quedaría a ver
2 al cuadrado es 4 3 x 4 es 12 menos 12
es igual a 0
ahí vamos bien y luego menos 2 efe prima
de menos 2 puede saber menos 2 al
cuadrado otra vez es 4 3 por 4 es 12
menos 12 otra vez nos da 0 entonces efe
prima de menos 2 es igual a cero y esto
lo que nos dice lo que nos dice es que 2
no voy a poner un poco más separado dos
y menos dos son
puntos críticos puntos críticos críticos
d
muy bien ahora el problema es que no
sabemos si son máximos o sea si hay un
máximo y un mínimo o ninguna de las dos
que podría pasar verdad como ya
platicamos entonces ahora lo que nos
gustaría ver es cómo cambia el signo de
la derivada el signo de la derivada
cuando cruzamos esos puntos déjame poner
aquí una gráfica vamos a graficar f
prima sal entonces vamos a graficar la
derivada no la función con un poco de
suerte después vamos a poder graficar la
función pero empezando con f prima y voy
a poner un eje y voy a poner otro eje
más o menos algo así sí más o menos algo
así está bien
entonces aquí está el eje y el eje x y
cómo se vería la gráfica de f prima pues
ve o sea una primera cosa que podemos
hacer déjame agarrar el color de la
derivada es evaluar en cero entonces efe
primer cero la deriva del cero es igual
a menos 12 - 12 eso nos da la ordenada
al origen entonces un punto de la
gráfica es el 0,12 menos 12 y otros dos
puntos que conocemos están dados por
estas raíces en 12 0 y en menos 2
también entonces aquí en dos miradas
está nuestra escala sí pero no le aquí
tenemos una escala en x y en ya tenemos
otra escala entonces estos puntos de acá
menos 20 20 y 0 como a menos 12 son
puntos de la gráfica de este modo la
derivada tiene más o menos esta gráfica
y luego llega a este punto
y luego empieza a subir
entonces esta es la gráfica de f prima
de x muy bien entonces qué sucede con f
prima de x cuando cruzamos menos 2 y 2
pues al principio antes de cruzar menos
2 tenemos que f prima es mayor que 0 en
este caso de acá sin mejorar el color
verde en este caso de acá tenemos que f
prima es mayor que 0 y en este caso de
acá tenemos que f prima es menor que
cero
efe prima es menor que cero entonces
mira cambiar de más a menos era nuestro
criterio para que en ese punto la
función original tuviera un máximo claro
hablando de puntos críticos entonces
este 2 este 2 corresponde déjame ponerlo
con un color que se note vamos a ponerlo
con blanco este 2 no perdón este menos 2
es en este punto de acá verdad es un
máximo máximo y ahora qué sucede en dos
ahora sí en dos pues en dos
efe prima es negativa estamos por abajo
del eje x
efe prima es negativa y después de
cruzar el 2
tenemos que f prima se hace positiva va
entonces aquí
efe prime es mayor que 0 de este lado f
prima es menor que cero y eso de ahí era
nuestro criterio para determinar que
teníamos un mínimo entonces en dos
tenemos un mínimo muy bien ahora está
nada más para volver a acordarnos de
cómo estaba la intuición de por qué de
más a menos nos da un máximo y de menos
a más o nos daba un mínimo voy a dibujar
aquí unas pequeñas gráficas y mira que o
sea que nos dice esto que nos dice que
la derivada sea mayor que cero en
términos de la función original pues nos
dice aquí voy a más o menos pintar a
esta altura porque sucede nos dice que
antes de este punto la función y es
creciente hasta que llega más o menos
acá y luego la derivada se hace negativa
y por tanto las funciones
por esta razón obtenemos un máximo en
este punto y de manera similar
trazando más o menos a esta altura a
esta altura la gráfica de la función
primero tenemos que la función es
decreciente entonces va bajando
va bajando hasta que llegamos a este
punto donde la derivada se hace cero y
como la derivadas de hace cero pues ahí
tenemos un punto crítico y qué sucede
después después tenemos que la función
empieza a crecer porque la derivada es
mayor que cero y por tanto aquí tenemos
un mínimo entonces estaría acá es mínimo
y este de acá es máximo muy bien vamos a
aprovechar esta intuición que recordamos
para ver si ahora podemos graficar pues
no no f prima de x sino fx entonces para
eso déjame irme para acá arriba y otra
vez pintar mis ejes más o menos a esa
altura ahí tenemos el eje y más o menos
por acá
por acá tenemos el eje x entonces vamos
a ver qué podemos decir vamos a regresar
nos a la función efe fx es estar acá
vamos a obtener su ordenada al origen
para mejorar el color amarillo entonces
efe efe ahora sí efe en 0 nos queda
igual a este 0 este 0 es igual a 4 vale
entonces
efe de 0 es igual a 4 entonces más o
menos estamos por este punto de acá es
el 0 4 más o menos como esa altura y que
más sabemos cada 3 - 2 y 2 son puntos
especiales entonces a lo mejor nos
conviene ver cuánto es efe de menos 2
para ver qué sucede acá entonces efe - 2
cuanto es menos 2 al cubo menos 2 x
menos dos es cuatro por menos 12 menos 8
menos 8 luego menos 2 por 12 2 por 2 es
24 menos por menos es más más 24 y luego
hay que sumar otros 4 aquí tenemos 24 y
cuatro es 28 menos 8 es igual a 20 ok
entonces mira esto está padre otro punto
que conocemos
voy a marcar dónde está el menos 2 y 2
porque son puntos importantes entonces
otro punto que conocemos es el menos
2,20 si éste ya que era 4 8 12 16 como
por acá queda al menos 220 y este es
otro punto de la gráfica de efe y mira
que sabemos de este punto de acá sabemos
que aquí hay un máximo entonces aquí
tenemos un máximo este tenemos que tener
que la función sea primero creciente y
luego decreciente entonces la gráfica se
vería más o menos así la gráfica de f la
función empieza a ser creciente y llega
hasta acá y después tiene que ser
decreciente entonces empieza a ser
decreciente decreciente y en algún
momento tiene que pasar por este punto
de acá
el que ya habíamos marcado más o menos
algo de este estilo
pero luego al acercarnos a dos al
acercarnos a dos pasa otra cosa verdad
cuando aquí la función sigue siendo
decreciente pero al llegar a dos pues
pasa esto de acá ahora en dos tenemos un
punto un punto mínimo vamos a ver cuánto
vale y efe en dos entonces lo voy a
escribir por acá
efe en 2 2 al cubo es 8 luego hay que
restar 24 y a eso tenemos que sumarle 4
cuánto nos queda en menos 24 4 es menos
20 más 8 es igual a menos 12 5 4 y 8 es
12 menos 24 nos da 12 ok entonces este
punto de acá bueno en este 2 debemos de
tener un valor igual a menos 12 este es
menos 12
20 y qué sucede después qué sucede una
vez que cruzamos el punto 2 pues ahora
la derivada del mayor que 0 y por tanto
la función se hace creciente y tiene que
hacer algo de este estilo vale
muy bien entonces bueno fíjate ya
logramos dos cosas ya este gracias a la
información de la derivada pudimos dar
un esbozo de cómo está dibujada la
función y pues también lo que ya lo que
queríamos encontrar desde el principio
verdad gracias a ver cómo cambia el
signo de la derivada logramos ver que
estos puntos críticos eran mínimos o
máximos entonces en dos teníamos un
punto mínimo que le correspondía el
menos 12 si menos 12 y en menos 2
teníamos un máximo que le correspondía
fd x igual a 20